hello everyone this game was played in
1981 between Stanislavski and my Konev
and the idea of Nakano head in this game
is well definitely worth a video but
you'll just have to see it you don't
have to believe me
sorry about my voice it seems my my fool
who got the best of me
star chefs is white in this game and
Nicola is black let's see it we have E 4
C 5 the Sicilian defense latter of 3
Knight to c6 and Bishop to b5 the
Russell emo attack we have e 6 Bishop
captures on c6 and B captures on c6 and
we have d3 so black has the bishop pair
and well white what did mess up black's
pawn structure somewhat we have g6 by
black and this is this is a correct move
as after the bishop talks to g7 he will
be very powerful here white castles and
we have Bishop to g7 and now e5 white
doesn't want to allow this bishop so
much power so he he limits his influence
we have a nice three seven Knight to c3
and black castles and knights three four
and well okay he is threatening some
Knight to d6 area so black pretty much
has to go for d5 although he might be
able to allow it with moves like rook to
b8 but he does play d5 and well it seems
almost a natural move to capture he
captures on this example son but if you
do this you get Knight to f5 and black
will win this d6 pawn eventually and
well you freed his dark squared bishop
so why doesn't decide to do this after
d5 he plays Knight captures on c5 and we
have a 92 f5 d for now any more
protection to the c5 pawn and rook to b8
kind of not allowing this Bishop to
develop but we have Bishop to g5 over
the tempo and the Queen Queen to c7
allow b3 guarding the pawn rook to b6
allow King to h1
making room for the rook lg1 we have a
five Queen to d2 and our Bishop tastes
exactly the rockin f1 on rook to g1 is
planned h6 Bishop to f6 Bishop captures
and pawn captures on f6 and this is a
very dangerous pawn white hands here and
f6 White's threat here is g4 kicking the
slide away from f5 and capturing with
the Queen m h6 so here we have King to
h7 and our g4 anyway Knight to Knight to
d6 and we have rook 81 Bishop to b5 and
this Bishop to b5 well it's not a very
good move black had black had better
moves here because he does have to stop
ideas like rook to g3 and rook to h3
when ideas of capturing on h6 so
probably probably Knight to e4 here
would have been better but okay he did
play Bishop to b5 and well here the best
move would be a rook to g3 followed by
rock to h3 but white had a different
idea and this is why this game is so
interesting he played Queen to f4
now this Knight is kind of pinned he can
freely move since the Queen is unguarded
and c7 we have Queen to d8 and the black
has the idea that he wants to play
Knight to e8 and capture this pawn on f6
so we have rook to e3 a brilliant idea
that starts with a rook lift we have
night to e8 now attacking this f6 pawn
and well what does white won't well
white wants to play rook to h3 this was
his idea he decided to go rookie three
and then somehow put the rock on h3 he
didn't want to play rook g3 and rook to
e3 because this was just too simple so
how does he put his rook to h3 well one
idea is Knight to g5 but this does give
White's still a better game but it's not
the best move white actually plays a
completely wild idea
he plays Knight to d7 and what is this
move doing well obviously he's attacking
both Brooks so what has to do something
about this
now of course he captures the light will
capture Sun d7 and now other night comes
to e5 would a temple on the Queen now
the screen goes back to e8 sorry d8 and
again black is threatening to capture
the pawn on f6 but now white again
sacrifices the light on the same square
with the same idea again playing Knight
to d7 sacrificing the second night
so again attacking both rooks and we
have twin captures on these seven and
now this rook can come to h3 so he does
rook to h3 is played
we have h5 not allowing the capture on
h6g captures on h5 and out g5 and of
course Queen to g5 and well what do you
play here we have Queen to d8 again
going for this f6 pawn and well here
white makes a little mistake he plays h6
but black didn't take advantage of it
black black can probably hold the game
if he plays a move like Bishop to f1
attacking this rook and while offering a
piece but black didn't find this move
and he played Queen captures on f6 and
unfortunately for him white plays Queen
to g7 with check and only movies maybe
not on the move Queen can capture the
Queen of course but he plays long
captures on g7 we have H captures on g7
with check and well if you clicking to
g8 you get a rope 288 checkmate so of
course like different playlists after H
capture stone g7 would check we have
Queen to h6
and now white brings out the brings back
one of the lights he sacrificed he plays
a G captors and f8 good night and this
is what check the Queen can't capture
because she's pinned only Maurice King
to h8 and you get rook captures on age
sex with checkmate oh and yeah I mean
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
it's quite a game does a double night
sacrifice on d7 for the sole purpose of
moving the root 2 H 3 was quite
ingenious
so yeah I couldn't find any information
and the players that played this given
stanishev ski in the corner of so if any
of you are able to do this please do
share in the comments I would like to
thank Alejandro pachi and the Tony Moore
guitar for a contribution to my channel
thank you really appreciate it as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here thank you all for watching and I'm
gonna go battle this flu with some rakia
now see you soon